all hell had broken loose Sophie could
barely believe she had survived for this
long getting used to one dramatic change
in her life was hard enough but almost
immediately after the entire world had
seemed to go crazy as a result she now
had a whole new existence to try and
adapt to Scavenging For What Little
scraps of food she could find in the
ruined desolate City the monsters could
appear at any time day or night either
one on their own or hold droves of the
nightmarish creatures that had been let
loose on the world this life was somehow
far more dangerous on a day-to-day basis
than her old one had been and given
Sophie used to work for the SCP
Foundation that really was saying
something formerly known as Dr
Cartwright she had been a researcher at
the foundation for a number of years
while she had been far from reaching the
upper echelons of the organization's
most notorious staff with the likes of
doctors Jack Bright and Kane pathos Crow
nobody could deny Sophie was an expert
when came to studying the anomalous as
much as she understood the importance of
their directive to safeguard Humanity
the foundation had first and foremost
been a job tour a means to an end
something to earn a living from and then
move on it wasn't worth giving up
everything for and when her life needed
more Focus than her work Sophie wasn't
hesitant to step away her mother had
fallen ill terminally and as a result
needed around-the-clock care so Dr
Sophie Cartwright had no choice but to
hand in her resignation from the SCP
Foundation there were times when she
missed it and moments after her mother
eventually passed that Sophie considered
going back but she came to realize it
wasn't the work itself she missed not
even her co-workers at the foundation it
was the occasional rare anomaly that was
just a completely harmless little Oddity
not a monstrous Abomination often in her
new unfamiliar life of resignation
Sophie would find herself off looking
wistfully at a picture of herself and
one such anomaly technically it was
against the foundation's rules to
possess any photographic evidence of
scps but Sophie had made sure it didn't
look like anything out of the ordinary
the picture had been taken on her phone
and showed Sophie crouching down with a
face of a curious but completely normal
looking black and gray tabby cat poking
up in the foreground nothing about the
picture gave any indication that the cat
named Josie was actually missing her
hindquarters and back legs as cp529 as
the foundation had designated her was
one of the few completely harmless scps
in their care her only anomalous trait
being that her entire back half was
missing either because it didn't exist
or had somehow been displaced in another
dimension hence her nickname Josie the
half-cat given that she had been allowed
to roam freely around the foundation
facility she was kept in Josie had run
across Dr Cartwright on number of times
the pair of them eventually becoming
friends with a sigh and smile Sophie had
been looking at the photo on the day
everything went wrong steel cap boots
came rushing up the stairs and down the
corridors to her apartment worn by a
group of black-clad mercenaries you see
unbeknownst to Sophie at the time she
had tendered her resignation from the
SCP Foundation a number of the
organization's higher-ups had also done
the same while Sophie's reasons for
leaving were purely personal the wave of
resignations from other high-ranking
Foundation Personnel came as a reaction
to something called project pneuma this
was an operation that had uncovered a
disturbing truth about the psychosphere
a shared human unconsciousness that had
led to the o5 council proposing a new
directive for the organization those
that objected left the foundation others
were killed by their former employer and
its merciless hit squads In Cold Blood
perhaps thanks to some administrative
error filing Sophie's resignation
alongside those that had left after
learning about pneuma or maybe because
the foundation didn't want her extensive
knowledge of the anomalous being used
against their Newfound directive they
had sent a mobile task force to her
apartment filing down the corridor the
soldiers lifted a battering ram and
swung It Forward shattering the door
wooden splinters littering the floor as
they breached the entrance but Sophie
had heard them coming escaping as fast
as she could descending a fire escape
ladder until she reached the street
below at that moment in time Sophie had
no idea why the foundation had sent a
hit squad out to kill her of course the
answer to that question quickly became
obvious shortly after reports came
pouring in from all over the world
broadcast over every News Channel before
they were ultimately blocked the SCP
Foundation had gone public revealing its
existence to the entire world and
declaring its new mission statement
rather than protecting the world from
anomalies the foundation had declared
war calling for the total and utter
distinction of humanity while Sophie had
no way of knowing the reasons for the
foundation going rogue it was clear that
working for them in the past had put a
Target on her back luckily she managed
to avoid the MTF coming after her
getting swept up in a crowd that was
fleeing from something far more horrific
scp-682 had been released and was
devouring people in broad daylight the
waking nightmare didn't stop there over
the next few months the foundation
released a number of dangerous anomalies
on the world using them to slaughter
innocent people in droves assassinate
world leaders and [ __ ] organizations
like the global occult coalition to
hinder Humanity's chances of fighting
back and amongst it all living through
the chaos and Carnage were tiny pockets
of survivors although those two were
starting to be rapidly picked off by the
foundation deploying more of their
mobile task force operatives or a
compliant scps to eliminate the refugees
Sophie had witnessed firsthand the found
foundation's attacks and as a result had
found it best to keep moving from Camp
to Camp only staying with one group of
fellow survivors for a few nights each
before moving on she wasn't sure if the
foundation was specifically attacking
the refugee camp she stopped at or if it
was a continuous systematic
extermination effort she'd been noting
down her ponderings in a half burned
notebook she had found while Scavenging
abandoned grocery stores for any
remaining food that was still edible a
cynical part of her thought that it was
perhaps pointless to document what was
happening but the former researcher and
Sophie wanted to preserve any
information she could about what the
foundation was subjecting people to if
anything that knowledge might prove
useful to someone in the future although
what future was a question Sophie
Cartwright kept returning to with no
optimistic answer in sight it was easy
to miss how things had once been to
yearn for life to get back to the way it
once was even though it was in possible
now that the anomalies were rampaging
the world over it made Sleeping hard the
fear of waking up to see the face of
scp-682 or scp-096 steering back at her
the moment she opened her eyes one night
it was worse than ever every sound no
matter how faint or far away in Sophie's
mind could have been made by a
carnivorous creature or an approaching
Foundation foot soldier a bottle clinked
waking Sophie from her Restless sleep
something was nearby and from the sound
of it it was getting closer and closer
sitting up in the alleyway she'd been
sleeping in so if he looked around her
feeling her heart thumping against her
ribs and fear then through the dark she
caught the sight of a pair of Beady
reflective eyes followed by the sounds
of a drawn-out defensive Yao for a
second she wondered if it could be no
surely not the eyes approached a small
shadowy form behind them so if he could
barely make it out in the night's
Darkness even with the glow of distant
fires in the sky on the horizon but from
what she could see the creature
approaching her was small just about
smaller than average cat about half the
size her fingers trembling she reached
out a hand towards it as gently as she
could allowing it to sniff her for a
moment then she felt it duck under her
open Palm letting her stroke up its
arched back when her hand reached about
halfway Sophie could feel the slight
yield of a barely tangible back half
which could only mean one thing Josie
Sophie asked holding a sob at the back
of her throat the little half cat
replied with a meow recognizing the
voice of Her human friend from the
foundation immediately she leaped into
the former researcher's lap allowing Dr
Cartwright to hold her and stroke her
giving in so glad to be reunited with
Josie Sophie started to let out stifled
sobbing sounds careful not to attract
attention but allowing herself to be the
happiest she'd felt in months in since
this had all started although she had no
way of understanding Josie's meows Dr
Cartwright assumed that The Brave Little
half cat had managed to escape the
foundation facility she used to call
home with relative ease and she was
right since Josie was allowed to roam
freely she had been able to make a break
for it when the foundation's MTF kill
squads opened fire on their own
Personnel at their various sites across
the globe the loud noise had caused
Josie the half cat to flee and hide
until the sounds of gunfire and screams
had all died down by the time she
emerged from her hiding place a number
of the anomalies once kept in
containment had now been set loose on
the world with a facility busted wide
open
scp-529 had taken it upon herself to
leave and had been surviving in much the
same way Sophie had Scavenging for
scraps passing from one refugee camp to
the next usually greeted with curiosity
by any ordinary civilian who had never
seen a cat with its entire our back half
missing now that they had been tearfully
reunited Josie and Sophie stuck together
on their continuing travels through the
now treacherous and scp-infested World
Sophie's entries in her makeshift
Journal started to take on much more
positive tones while it was hard to be
entirely optimistic living through an
anomalous apocalypse her spirits were at
least lifted by having her little half
cat companion alongside her Josie never
seemed to stray too far from Sophie's
side as they hiked their way across the
country occasionally scp-529 would climb
up her human friends back and rest on
her shoulders as they traversed more
open terrain her missing back half
making it look like the little half cat
was perched precariously on her front
two legs next to Sophie's head and of
course whenever they stopped the night
Josie would sleep curled up and purring
contentedly right next to Sophie when
the next morning came she would awaken
stretch out her front paws with a yawn
then nuzzle at Sophie sleeping face to
wake her up at first Dr Cartwright's
plan had been to head Due West from
where she had started hoping to reach
Yellowstone National Park and access
scp-2000 there was a foundation facility
there hidden deep underground and filled
with all manner of anomalous technology
it was all intended to be used in case
the world ended and the human race was
wiped out even capable of mass producing
new human beings with customized
memories as well as holding a backup of
all cumulative knowledge and data on
Earth every book ever written every
terabyte of information on the internet
everything however passing through
another Camp Sophie and Josie receive
word from one of the other survivors
apparently the foundation had predicted
that somebody with knowledge of scp-2000
might try something like that and how it
would undermine their plans to wipe out
Humanity during one of the moments where
rebelling groups were able to
temporarily restore TV and internet
service it was reported that the
foundation had already put stop to that
potential option from reverting their
apocalypse they had intentionally
triggered an eruption of the Yellowstone
supervolcano totally obliterating the
facility housing scp-2000 and one of
Humanity's last hopes at survival well
thanks for telling me Sophie's Side by
now she had long given up almost all
hope that things would ever be the same
again but hearing the news about
Yellowstone have extinguished the last
little Ember of optimism that she had
left there was no way back sensing her
friend was upset Josie meowed at her
either as if to tell Sophie it's okay or
I'm hungry as the pair turned to leave
though the other Survivor called out at
them wait they said look I I heard
another rumor and it might be a total
myth but there's meant to be a sanctuary
not far from here what do you mean
Sanctuary Sophie asked like another Camp
the foundation will wipe it out within a
week no not a camp the Survivor replied
it's just a rumor but supposedly there's
a refuge some place where the SCP
Foundation can't get to apparently
there's a shelter as well as plenty of
food and water probably enough for you
and the little one Sophie looked out of
the corner of Ariah Josie balanced on
her shoulder the pair of them had gone
weeks without eating before arriving at
this camp and she had no idea how long
it would be before they reached the next
the side of her half-cat companion
motivated her they needed to survive as
long as they did the foundation couldn't
win given the other Survivor a nod they
pointed her in the right direction that
way a few miles at least but you gotta
be careful getting through the forest
they explained be careful the
foundations got people out on patrols
over there they're real weird too I seen
them doing this strange ritual letting
their Commander stab them testing
whether they can still feel pain or not
within a few hours the sun had set with
both Sophie and Josie deep in the heart
of the woods just like every night since
the foundation had initiated their war
on Humanity ever every sound every snap
twig or rustling leaves in the breeze
filled Sophie with Dread but this time
at least she knew with certainty that
there were MTF troops nearby she could
see their flashlights beams of light
bleeding through between the trees
carefully holding Josie In Her Arms she
stepped carefully and quietly as she
could through the forest the half cat
was trembling clearly feeling just as
fearful as Sophie was the former
researcher was praying that her little
friend wouldn't make a sound she knew
she wouldn't be able to help it if she
did cats did instinctively make
defensive yells if they felt threatened
but even the slightest noise from Josie
would give away their position to the
MTF sweeping the area fan out she heard
the task Force's field commander call he
even spread if there's anyone here you
all know what to do Sophie ducked down
behind a Fallen Tree covering her own
mouth with her free hand trying to stop
her Panic breathing her only option were
to make a break for it dashing through
the forest in hope she and Josie weren't
caught or Worse killed though these days
there was really no difference between
the two or she could wait for the MTF to
pass by continuing their search she had
spent months trying to survive in this
anomalous apocalyptic nightmare by now
the foundation couldn't have known she
was there their forces were just calming
the forest looking for any survivors
they could find but if she stayed still
there was still a chance one of the MTF
would find her in Josie and would either
alert the others or just open fire on
the spot All Things Considered neither
option sounded ideal Josie was getting
restless trying to wriggle free of
Sophie's grip the afcats incorporeal
back half meant Sophie could only hold
what little Underside the feline friend
had slowly she started to get up and
made her way out from behind the tree
right into the path of an MTF trooper's
flashlight got a live one he yelled a
flash of light and a loud bang echoed
through the forest the bullet had torn
through Sophie's chest nearly missing
her half cat but the noise of the shot
had been more than enough to startle her
as Sophie dropped to the forest floor
gripping her heavily bleeding wound and
writhing in pain Josie leaped into the
air towards the foundation operative
either in shock or because she somehow
understood her protector had been shot
The Brave Little Cat started clawing at
the soldier's face despite her sharp
front claws tearing at him leaving red
lines over his face the armed man didn't
react it was as if he couldn't feel pain
at all the MTF Trooper gripped Josie by
the neck fur pulling her away from him
before he could reach for his sidearm
someone charged at him knocking the
foundation operator over another shot
rang out as he fell tackled by Sophie
meanwhile Josie had dropped to the
ground landing on her two visible feet
and hissing at the soldier scrambling to
her feet Sophie picked up Josie and ran
the sounds of the rest of the task force
receding into the distance behind her
the little half cat was looking back
over her human friend's shoulder
watching as the sweeping flashlights of
the MTF kill Squad fan between the trees
until they eventually disappeared from
view her earlier adrenaline Spike began
to drop sharply in time with a gradual
rise of the sun Sophie had long since
slowed down certain that she'd be able
to give the foundation's foot soldiers
the slip Josie had taken her favorite
perch on Sophie's shoulder again meaning
she could use her hands to apply
pressure to her two wounds but with
every step the former researcher could
feel her limbs getting heavier her pulse
which had drum faster than ever as her
and her half-cat had fled was now
slowing down with every fading beat she
was tired so much that she could barely
keep her head up until eventually Sophie
had to stop she sat at the edge of a
lake in the middle of the forest
exhaustedly trying to catch her breath
calmly Josie hopped off her shoulder and
sat down at her side licking her paw and
cleaning behind her ears Sophie looked
at her little friend and smiled feeling
a tear run down her face she reached
into her bag and produced her journal
tearing out a page and scrolling down a
note with the last for strength to
whoever finds this half cat her name is
Josie she's my only friend left in the
whole world I've taken care of her for
as long as I can but I'll be dead soon
please take care of her for me take her
to safety be good to her and she'll be
good to you and if you scavenge any
cheese only give her a little as a treat
after tying the note to Josie's
midsection so it rested atop her
semi-corporeal back half Sophie looked
around one last time the lake was calm a
tiny pocket of remaining peace in a
world gone mad overrun with anomalies
guess we didn't make it to a sanctuary
after all Josie she whispered weakly
giving her little half cat one last
scratch behind the ears Josie meowed
gratefully finally unable to keep her
eyes open and her head up any longer
Sophie Cartwright let herself drift off
Josie was left meowing at her friend to
to wake up she sat with her all day she
didn't move didn't even wake up when
Josie nestled her face against hers like
she had before Sophie's face felt much
colder now against the confused half
cat's fur eventually Josie wandered off
into the forest towards an uncertain
future maybe if this future wasn't set
in stone if it could be reset then Josie
the half-cat would see her friend Sophie
again now go and check out scp-5000 the
full story compilation if you want to
know more about the events that led up
to now or take a little trip back in
time and spend a day with Josie the half
cat in his scp-999 no longer the cutest
SCP
scp-529 Josie the half cat